[Music]
all right guys there's this
really cool new invention that's gonna
be
life-saving uh so canadian researchers
they have introduced this new breathing
device
that requires no special training but is
able to
reduce severe alcohol intoxication so
what breathing machine it will take away
your intoxication so like if you just
want to sober up
you put the machine and then you breathe
and then you're just like all right i'm
not drunk no more yeah
what it's like for breathing it's like
the back of the future three juice
like the hot sauce juice that he makes i
don't remember that we don't know that
he gives it to doc brown and then doc
brown oh yeah yeah
when he's in the western yeah dude he's
so drunk that he's like knocked out and
they were like
if you just give him this drink he'll
sober up right now he'll be sober
he runs out and like dunks his head in
like the the horse water yeah and then
he's
back oh
my favorites number two me too it
combines like westerns but like that
can't be kind of fun way
it's fun i like it too as well yeah but
i like to because it's fake future
yeah i like it dude you know we already
passed the future
i know of that date really yeah
we missed out on those hoverboards what
was the date 2015. yeah it was like
october 20 or something yeah yeah
we got the boring hoverboards the one
that you face horizontally they suck
it doesn't really hover you're not
really like above just the stupid wheel
anyway so back to this thing so uh
they're saying
that the reason why alcohol is such
a prominent killer in this country is
because
the liver is the one that's processing
the alcohol but
when you drink too much or like the fact
that like you you
end up drinking you're drunk but then
you drink some more it just makes you
more drunk like it just like it it
builds up right and it's because of the
fact that your liver
your liver can't process alcohol
at the rate that you are consuming it so
that's the reason why like your liver is
backed up yeah
and so that's why a lot of people can
become
uh they could have alcohol intoxication
or
alcohol poisoning and that's when you
have to go to the hospital
and get it pumped out of your stomach
and they also give you like charcoal or
some [ __ ] to absorb the alcohol and like
it's just the fact that your liver isn't
able to process the amount of alcohol
that you put in your body
and that's why it's so dangerous that's
why people stay drunk for a long time
and that's where you get hangovers and
all that [ __ ] right so this device here
it's it has like a gas mask and it's
connected to a supply of oxygen and
carbon dioxide
and it reduces drunkenness because
the lungs are also it also plays a part
in
your body processing the alcohol which a
lot of us
don't really think about we just think
about our liver right but our lungs also
play a role and so when blood soaked
when alcohol soaked blood reaches the
lungs
it ends up supplying it a fresh batch of
oxygen
and then that's when the organs uh are
aren't able to keep up with it and so
they're
intoxicated right like that's how you're
intoxicated that's actually
the reason why breathalyzers work to
detect alcohol
and your breath and that's the reason
why your breath stinks of booze too
because your lungs are also
trying to process the alcohol and so
with this device here and it's
taking it's taking the oxygen
and providing just enough carbon dioxide
to
neutralize it yeah like to help your
body process
the alcohol and make you less drunk as
you're breathing in
you can process it faster yeah like it's
it's helping your
your [ __ ] look so stupid
yeah i would make fun of anybody yo that
looks like just the water bottle with
the
well this is a very common device that
they use in the hospital
yeah like the cpr machine oh like this
is the
the new device but this thing they use
it all the time to like provide oxygen
to people that
aren't able to breathe like they're just
stupid looking people
that'd be sick though because like
getting home after like drinking a bunch
at night and then you're laying there in
bed and things are spitting
you're like man i just want to sober up
and go to sleep god i'll never forget
that
the last time that happened to me it was
my mid-20s i never want to go back to
that
so you don't drink to that point no more
you drink a lot vinnie
i can't i can't drink a lot but i don't
drink to that point that's crazy you
never get to the point where you drink
so much though that you can't control
how much you drink after
no no no because you're not ever at that
point no no no
i don't get [ __ ] up or anything like
that but cheers to that am i right
bro yeah it's by the way it's 12 30 in
the morning in the morning in the middle
of the night wow
wishing late today bad little sippers no
the last time i got
like stupid like that it was uh early
october
and that was the last time because i
quit drinking since then
earlier that's it you don't drink no
more too much
yeah it was too [ __ ] like it was it
was too much like forever
i don't know about forever but no so
casey and i actually made a pact because
we were
so during quarantine we started drinking
some more and then we we like
we're like oh [ __ ] we're drinking too
much we cut back and then we're just
like oh let's just drink a little bit
here and there like occasionally here
during our
shooting and then um but then like that
i had this one night or it was like
way too much and i didn't realize i had
drank that much
and then did you know you were throwing
up yeah i was throwing up and then the
next day it was like a horrible hangover
and i'm like oh [ __ ]
that's that 14 year old party girl [ __ ]
and you crash both your cars together
no it was just one of those like like
situations where
just with the environment i didn't even
realize there was this one moment where
i chugged a whole
thing of water and i thought it was
water but it was tequila oh my god
that's how drunk you were dropped to the
point where alcohol doesn't taste like
alcohol
yeah that's where i know so then i was
like okay
listen i can't drink anymore like this
is too [ __ ] crazy and then also since
we're trying to get pregnant we're like
this isn't a good idea
like let's just not does it [ __ ] with
the uh chances of getting pregnant
i thought everyone gets pregnant while
they were drunk yeah i thought i thought
drunk [ __ ] got you pregnant i know
that's what i thought too but apparently
it doesn't
help so we just quit it we also quit
coffee too
oh [ __ ] that's cool yeah we quit boy so
your morning suck and your evenings suck
that was my entire morning this morning
oh [ __ ] oh my gosh
i quit caffeine illegal under their
politics i know it's illegal
no but yeah we ended up making a pact so
like we're just like
you're helping each other out yeah we're
helping each other out well recently
over the weekend we did this
big mood shoot and i asked him i'm like
is it okay if i just have one glass of
wine because like the girls are
like all here and he's like yeah so
that's it like we're we're like
communicating that's cool
just keeping each other up with each
other yeah keep it yeah exactly
i quit drinking just one glass it's fine
no yeah
i know listen one turns into two
and it starts again though a couple
lines of coke
and i'm like hey we're cool right and
then he's like yeah and i'm like you
have
a glass of wine too where did the
caffeine come to play oh the caffeine
was also because we're the
trying to get pregnancy um that [ __ ]
could [ __ ] up the pregnancy too
yeah like well it it's it has been
linked to
a to like miscarriages and stuff so if i
do get pregnant
then i assume anything that kind of
changes your body yeah like there's more
of a possibility
to possibly have a miscarriage or
whatever and then also i just don't want
to have like a mega hyper
kid i guess i don't know i just i'm like
listen just all natural
can you text casey and see if it's okay
if we do birthday shots because it's
nelson's birthday today
oh no i don't want to take a shot more
birthday shots
oh we also just said like if it's red
wine
then if we ask then just one glass and
then we're cool
but other than that now we're good okay
birthday shot of red wine
[Laughter]
so you said you quit caffeine too i
couldn't do it for um
more than a month yeah but like one week
i was happy it was it was having a crazy
headache headache really bad
yeah where do you get it here on the
side in front i don't remember i don't
usually get headaches but it was it was
it was just [ __ ] crazy for the first
few days but the one yeah i get it right
here if i don't have the caffeine
i notice that in the back of your head
like oh i drink a ton of caffeine but i
don't feel like i've ever had the
caffeine headaches
how many days have you gone without it
yeah but you never not drink for a day
no i have like last weekend i think it
just happened to not drink for a couple
days because i was like out and doing
stuff
and i just didn't now it's mine came in
day three i was like
i didn't get it the first two days but
then i drink so much caffeine too i'll
start my day with coffee and then drink
pre-workout to go work out
and then afterwards i'll have like an
afternoon coffee so i can like
keep staying focused and doing work try
the challenge you might just have
caffeine in your system that will last
you for like days
i still technically am consuming
caffeine and it's
only through matcha though so it's a
drooby shout out
i think i've drank so much monster
energy over the years that even
if i go because i recently i was at a
wedding and i didn't have monster that
whole day
and but if i crack my knuckles i think
the sediments of like holy [ __ ]
and it's released in your system yeah
you just got another like mini here
i'm hiding out in there yeah it's like
how we have fat store
you got caffeine exactly i think so i
got deposits
that's cool you're like meaning you you
look for someone who does a really good
massage i'm gonna hey quick crack my
back
pick me up release the caffeine i swear
yeah that's pretty intense i think the
worst for me was uh quitting sugar
that was actually the worst more than
quitting any drug anything did you get
headaches too from the sugar
it was not only headaches i would wake
up in the middle of the night
like in shock and it was crazier man
like
than any [ __ ] hard drug in the world
like the craziest withdrawal
yeah it was the craziest oh damn yeah
like
what other symptoms did you have uh like
mood swings just the regular
like withdrawal symptoms but the worst
was um waking up
in shock in the middle of the night and
then like wanting something and then
like
having like the i guess it's a panic
attack or whatever you call it like you
wake up and you're just like oh [ __ ]
like you're being chased and then you're
like i need some sugar right now or some
sweets
yeah yeah that's intense yeah i only
could last about a month for that too
it was pretty crazy oh yeah back to this
device here though
so it's actually really exciting to hear
about an invention like this because i
could easily see this
in bars and like you know how people
can't like they end up leaving bars
and they're still intoxicated they get
in their car they cause crazy accidents
it kills a lot of people
but this could be like saving a lot of
lives if
she put that in an uber so when people
come in it's like don't barf in the back
seat
just here breathe because all you're
doing is just breathing
it's just like it's kind of like a
controlled hyperventilation
but like hyperventilation itself they're
saying that it can be very dangerous
because our bodies are
being deprived of necessary carbon
dioxide
and that's the reason why some people
faint when they panic and they breathe
rapidly
but then with this device it ends up
giving you just enough
carbon dioxide to to not give you those
triggers
that's crazy how breathing can like
sober you up
i know right yes i feel like people are
so stupid though they're gonna be like
oh you got that [ __ ] we'll get extra
[ __ ] up today
get [ __ ] up and then take a hit of
that get [ __ ] up take a hit of that
yeah
definitely drive to the store yeah
have you seen the movie flight i've seen
it on a movie oh yeah it's
how i'm i've seen this off a movie that
time you're talking about flight
from his own eyeballs you're talking
about the denzel washington movie flight
right
um no i never oh [ __ ] no that's the
movie you watch
oh yeah that's the one i watched that's
the best one about it i swear to you
yeah
[Music]
okay
[Music]
you